non come oggi fa applicare formula
creata da tutto
no no io ci parlare di totò isaac newton
che non essere su frigo vice newton dice
che moto no che einstein youth dice che
corpo finché una cavità isaac newton
dice che corpo man genere stato di
quiete o moto rettilineo di forum e
finché forza un ace su di esso
adesso noi dimostrare che questo
esperimento funzionare mediante utilizzo
di nuove e sempre più scontento di fare
questo insieme segalina incazzarsi top
prove ammazzare tutti potendo dovrebbe
ha ritrovato gallina alle 7 del mattino
di no capace dottor a riprender gallina
paura almeno ci abbia dato parte linear
cortesia noi noi dottore non riuscire
non riesco stimola chi è ridotto ben
mangiato to cucina calignano voler fare
questo ma riesco a un hacker philip
meyer di herat insieme
[Musica]
[Applauso]
there are gallina esattamente non è
collegato gallina pare verso di cani non
essere normale questa cosa mi becca io
vi ammazzo tutti regala gallinaro di
volere morire
occorre prendere uovo gallina spostare
ok affidare per cortesia costa non
esserci uovo dottore prezzo per i
fondelli atteso tutto le pare amicizia
ora prendere gallina perfetto kalina
anni ed il dott
over perché totò amico degli animali
no ragazzi
spero l'ha adottata per un po di paura
quindi adesso spostare totale a prendere
uovo dover restituire promesso
cominciamo che onestamente prova del
fallimento prendere bicchiere di acqua
metterle sotto abbassò joan chen mettere
sopra vassoio oa quello di carta
igienica what was preso qui in
precedenza da galina molto gentile
mettere sopra rotoli di carditello
adesso settore applicare legge di newton
viaggi di minuti dice che se totò metà
reina motta luogo cadere dottore 32
esperimento di totò era insito occorre
prepararsi per loro in film su re play
carne studenti poi vedere forza di
gravità che arci si sull'uomo suv agisce
suo sì come totò verdi cere sfide a che
esso provar esperimento non con uno non
con due una con 34 mi chiedo
[Musica]
ottalevi pronto ferramenta le difficoltà
di esperimento perché un nuovo nova sarà
il dottore presi 4 sarà preso anche
coloni olimpiadi perché questa
svenimento valere per ogni più dover
riempire ogni bicchiere di color
musichetta che reina grazie
[Musica]
la tav è pronto bicchieri al centro di
calore e metterle assoluto quanto per
esperimento della vita inserito a rotoli
in posizione corretta inserire ultimo
ingrediente cioè carina ancora non
formata siamo pronti per parte finale di
esperimenti tutti in sé ambienti di
tutorial qatar e dottori manocchi in
paventi mattatore non aver fatto un
territorio riuscire dove mi segno di
qualcosa di motivazionale cosa farà
cantare canzoni al dottore
[Musica]
per patria di totale dovrà essere
riuscito l'esperimento solo mancato un
bicchiere tolle centrato esperimento
trequarti riuscito totale quindi
terminate scadimento lasciate mi piace a
viversi video piaciuto ricordare non
fare a casa perché se no mamma picchiare
esperimento concluso tutorie contento
trattori adesso tornare a fare
esperimenti meglio tutto torre leader e
di metterle mi piace video iscrivetevi
al canale il titolare per altri
esperimenti noi ci vedeva il prossimo
episodio toga andare a limana le foto di
newton quello non essere newton 9
[Musica]